عندما اعتلى سده الحكم في الكويت اواخر
سبتمبر من العام 2020 كان الشيخ نواف
الاحمد الجابر الصباح اسما معروفا في
الواجهه السياسيه الكويتيه
فمسهد بادوار بارزه في تحديث قطعي
الداخليه والدفاع وهما حقيبت وزيت تلاهما
في فترتين
مختلفتين ولد الشيخ نواف في الخ من يونيو
من عام
197 30 وهو الابن السادس لعاشر امراء
الكويت الشيخ احمد الجابر الصباح والاخ
غير الشقيق للامير السابق الشيخ صباح
الاحمد الصباح على امتداد سته عقود تولى
الشيخ نواف مناصب عده في الدوله بداها
محافظا لمحافظه حولي عام 62 واستمر في هذا
المنصب 16 عاما كان له دور بارز في وزاره
الداخليه الكويتيه التي تولاها اول مره في
عام
78 وبقيت في عهدته 10 اعوام ثم تولاها
ثانيه عندما عاد الى الحكومه عام
2003 خلال هاتين الفترتين كانت له بصمات
مشهوده في تطوير المنظومه الامنيه
الكويتيه وتحديث قطاعاتها وكذلك في تطوير
العمل الشرطي اما وزاره الدفاع فتولاها
بدايه عام
88 ثم عاد اليها عام 90 تمت تزكيه الشيخ
نواف وليا للعهد عام 2006 وعمل الى جانب
اخيه الراحل الشيخ صباح الاحمد حتى وفاته
عام
2020 بعدها ادى الشيخ نواف الاحمد الجابر
الصباح اليمين الدستوريه اميرا للبلاد حتى
وفاته عن 86 عاما وبذلك ادل الستار على
مسيره احد رجالات الكويت التاريخيين الذي
عاصر سار بناء الدوله الحديثه واسهم في
بعث نهضتها